in the last video where we assumed a
floating exchange rate we saw how a
trade imbalance could lead to the
exchange rate changing and how that
could resolve the trade imbalance in the
last situation at a six UN per dollar
exchange rate we had this Chinese
manufacturer having 50 million dollars
of Revenue in the United States that he
needed to convert into un so that was
the supply of dollars we had the u.s.
manufacturer selling 120 million yen
worth of software in China that he had
to convert into 20 million dollars so
that was the demand for dollars since
the demand for dollars was so much less
than the supply of dollars the price of
the dollar went down in terms of the
when so the when became stronger and the
dollar became weaker so instead of
having 61 per dollar maybe it would be
five when per dollar or four when per
dollar and so eventually if that
happened the Chinese manufacturer would
have to raise its prices in the United
States which would lower its demand and
the u.s. manufacturer could lower its
prices in China which would increase its
demand and that would eventually resolve
the trade imbalance but let's say that
the People's Bank of China does not like
this situation it wants to keep the
trade imbalance and so it figures out
that the only way to keep the trade
imbalance is to keep its currency pegged
at six UN per one dollar
how does it go about doing that well it
just has to resolve the imbalance in
supply and demand for the US dollar at
this exchange rate so how does it do
that in this situation there was a
supply of 50 million dollars there was
only demand for 20 million dollars
there was only a demand for 20 million
dollars of when being converted into
dollars so essentially what the Chinese
central bank can do is make up the
difference it can say it can literally
just print it can literally just print
180 million won it can literally just
print 180 million un and say I want to
convert that into dollars and then it
tries to convert that to dollars well
180 million un if you divide it by six
that exchange rate that would create an
incremental demand for 30 million more
US dollars 30 million u.s. dollars now
well how is the supply and demand
equation the supply is 50 million US
dollars
the demand is 20 million US dollars from
the American manufacturer and now
another 30 million US dollars from the
Chinese central bank so now it's equal
so now the exchange rates actually won't
move relative to each other
and the trade imbalance can go on